[Applaus]
[Musik]
er kennt sie alle aus dem
geschichtsunterricht die steinzeit die
eisenzeit und als wäre es gestern
gewesen die brose zeitabschnitte der
menschheitsgeschichte die nach dem
jeweils dominierenden material zur
herstellung von waffen und werkzeugen
benannt wurden wissen jedoch wie unser
zeitalter heißen wird falls zukünftiger
historiker auch auf dieses namensschema
zugreifen sollten kommt hier drauf also
ich will euch nicht auf die folter
spannen
wir befinden uns gerade jetzt in der
hand an ideen zeit landtag was
bitteschön okay schon merkwürdig denn
ich bin mir sicher dass die meisten
menschen noch nie was von unternehmen
gehört haben was erzählt uns dieser typ
also vom namen eines zeitalters dessen
zeitgenossen null ahnung haben wovon
überhaupt die rede ist okay ich versuche
es noch mal sicher habt ihr hier und da
ein paar nachrichten über sogenannte
seltene erden gesehen da hat es klick
gemacht genau die rede ist von 17
chemischen elementen wie aufgrund ihrer
verwendung in einer vielzahl von geräten
eine phänomenale bedeutung für die
weltwirtschaft erlangt haben
wahrscheinlich eine noch größere als
zinkoxid aber keine angst dass hier wird
keine in filmchen über chemie im alltag
eine hausfrau nein heute geht es um
knallharte geopolitik einen wirtschafts
thriller der die globalen
machtverhältnisse basieren da
durcheinanderwirbeln könnte als corona
denn ausgerechnet china ist derzeit der
weltweit größte produzent der seltenen
werden und im grunde ist es nur eine
frage der zeit wann die asiatischen
supermacht das über geht diese begehrten
metalle als gewichtiges druckmittel in
ihrer internationalen politischen
strategie zu nutzen
die fragen lauten also auf welche weise
kann und wird china seine dominanz auf
dem globalen markt für seltene erden
ausnutzen warum sie diese eigentlich so
wichtig und welche alternative hat der
rest der welt falls peking beginnt die
schlinge zu ziehen
heute werden wir hier bei dieser politik
all diese fragen beantworten aber dass
uns zunächst einen blick auf brent wenig
geschichte werfen
china aus erdöl
die erste überraschung wenn man sich mit
dem seltenerdmetall beschäftigt erlebt
man schon bei ihrem namen denn in
wahrheit sind die vorkommen einiger
dieser metalle gewaltig zb nickel kupfer
zink oder blei selbst die seltensten von
ihnen sind 200 mal häufiger in der natur
zu finden als gold wäre es da nicht
besser statt seltene erden zum beispiel
heute geehrten zu sagen nun nicht
unbedingt wenn das problem ist dass die
seltenen erden in extrem geringen
konzentrationen vorkommen selbst in den
reichsten vorkommen sind diese 17 der
von elemente nur in konzentration von
maximal zwei prozent zu finden
[Musik]
und tatsache ist nun mal das selten
ärger zu einem wichtigen rohstoff für
die herstellung von hightech produkten
geworden sind wir reden hier von allen
arten elektronischer geräte wie
bildschirmen kurzem abschluss und so
richtig explodiert ist die bedeutung
sollten die gebühren im verbrauch
fossiler brennstoffe zu reduzieren ohne
sie in puncto herstellung von akkus für
elektroautos da nicht mehr das gleiche
gilt für die dauer magnete in
windkraftanlagen neodym und samaria
merkt euch diese namen was so klingt wie
das neue brasilianische stürmer von
parreiras sind in wirklichkeit zwei
weitere lanthanoide die begehrtesten in
der rüstungsindustrie aufgrund ihrer
eigenschaften sind sie ideal für
präzisions lenksystem von raketen und
intelligente bomben sowie für den
einsatz im drohnen und flugzeug
es sollte also niemanden überraschen
wenn wir auf schlagzeilen wie diese
stoßen china erzielt auf
exportbeschränkungen für seltene erden
um die us rüstungsindustrie zu behindern
wir alle gut ist ist der shooting star
auf dem weltmarkt für militärflugzeuge
die f35 des us herstellers lockheed und
für die herstellung geht es dieser
flugzeuge werden nicht weniger als 4 117
kilogramm an seltenen erden benötigt das
sind drei prozent des gesamtgewichts
jeder fw33 wie aber konnte es überhaupt
so weit kommt dass die so wichtige
amerikanische verteidigungsindustrie von
entscheidungen der chinesischen
kommunistischen partei abhängig geworden
ist
nun bis in den 1980 er jahre
wir haben die vereinigten staaten
weltweit in der förderung der meisten
dieser 17 chemische elemente führend die
mine und aufbereitungsanlage mount
pleasant bundesstaat kalifornien war
jahrzehnte lang der weltgrößte lieferant
von sätteln und förderte bis zu 20.000
tonnen erz pro tag alles der in noten
test gewonnen landrat woide europa macht
überhaupt erst das farbfernsehen möglich
allerdings war die ausbeutung von lantal
ihn nie besonders attraktiv wie gesagt
sind diese mineralien selbst in den
westen gingen in nur sehr geringen
konzentration zu finden und es ist sehr
schwierig und teuer sie in großem
maßstab zu gewinnen und an dieser stelle
kommen die chinesischen fünfjahrespläne
endspiel sieht realisierten gezielt den
abbau seltener erden vielleicht mehr aus
geostrategischen denn aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen eine
entscheidung der allerhöchsten spitzen
der kp hier
denn schon der urvater des modernen
china denkt shopping sagte folgendes es
gibt pläne an osten und china hat
seltene erden denn chinas führer am ende
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts dass china
den heutigen internationalen markt für
seltene erden dominiert liegt jedoch vor
allem an der chinesischen gewinnungs
methode
[Musik]
denn neben ihrer geringen konzentration
ist ein weiteres charakteristisches
merkmal der seltenen erden dass sie nur
sehr schwer von dem gestein indem sie
vorkommen zu trennen sind uns die
chemikalie verwendet werden um diese
metalle aus dem erst zu gewinnen
verursachen extrem giftige abfälle die
entsorgung dieses typischen müsste sogar
radioaktiv ist erhöht also die
wirtschaftlichen kosten dieser
bergbaubetriebe in erheblichen maße aber
machen wir uns nichts vor
umweltverschmutzung hat sich china
traditionell nie besonders geschert das
war ein enormer vorteil im
internationalen wettbewerb so dass die
produktion im großen stil hochgefahren
werden konnte
währenddessen stürzten die preise dieser
metalle jedoch ab was die rentabilität
der mine in anderen ländern zunichte
machte und sich zur schließung
chinesische produzenten nutzten ihre
vorteile praktisch nicht vorhanden oder
umweltstandards und niedrige löhne
auf diese weise übernahmen china die
kontrolle über den globalen markt zu
seltener erden bis zum ende des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts hatte es china
geschafft die ausländische konkurrenz
auszulöschen und 97 prozent der
weltproduktion an sich zu reißen tja
dann startete das kommunistische regime
die zweite phase seines plans
[Musik]
17 metalle um sie alle zu knechten china
nahm nach und nach bei seltenen erden
eine ähnliche rolle ein
wie die opec öl peking erlangte eine art
monopolstellung und versuchte einen
jahrzehnte die seltenen erden er im
streit mit japan für politische zwecke
auszunutzen wie ihr wisst hat japan
einen bedeutung der elektronik- und
automobilindustrie und verbraucht gerade
deshalb eine fünftel der gesamten
weltproduktion an selten werden deswegen
geriet seine wirtschaft ist als jener
2010 exporte werden in das land der
aufgehenden sonne blockierte nachdem es
zu einem diplomatischen zwischenfall den
des festhaltens eines chinesischen
reiches in japanischen hoheitsgewässern
gekommen war
die peking als seine eigenen anspruch
japan prangerte china bei der
welthandelsorganisation wto an und china
musste einen rückzieher machen als die
vereinigten staaten und die europäische
union
die japanischen schweren unterstützten
die droh peking stand jedoch nach wie
vor im raum
denn all das hindert ihn nicht daran
seine exporte von seltenen erden jahr
für jahr schrittweise zu reduzieren und
nicht zu vergessen
es ist nicht nur so dass das
kommunistische regime die wirtschaft
rivalisierender möchte absichtlich
schädigen wollte es war vor allem eine
betriebswirtschaftliche frage zunächst
einmal bei der abbau von seltenen erden
teuer ist wenn man also das angebot
reduziert aber einem markt auf dem die
nachfrage stetig steigt
ihr könnt euch das ergebnis vorstellen
die preise für seltene erden steigen
aufgrund des knappen angebots
denn das wichtigste ist dass china nicht
nur ein exporteur dieses rohstoffs ist
der wichtige entscheidende punkt ist
dass es praktisch zum einzigen land
geworden ist dass eine verarbeitende
industrie entwickelt hat welche diese
metalle raffiniert und in
gebrauchsfertige materialien so die
hersteller verwandelt china kontrolliert
etwa 80 prozent der weltweiten
raffinerie kapazitäten für seltene erden
das geht so weit dass sogar die usa ihre
dort geförderten mineralien china
schicken müssen
der asiatische riese erkannte also was
für ein riesiges geschäft er trat in den
händen hielt und endete schnell seine
strategie seit 2015 hat hier noch viele
nicht lizenziert termin zur ausbeutung
von seltenen erden geschlossen und sich
darauf konzentriert diese metalle aus
anderen ländern importieren die käufe
von seltenen erden aus übersee haben
sich in drei jahren verzehnfacht im jahr
china ist der weltweit führende anbieter
von seltenen erden konzentrat soli
verlören malaysia und vietnam 25 prozent
aller seltenen erden die von der
chinesischen industrie verarbeitet
werden und da viele neue technologien
für einen nachfrage boom sorgte der
preisanstieg bei den andern lieben das
so dass der abbau von seltenen erden in
anderen ländern wieder wirtschaftlich
rentabel geworden ist da china aber auch
eine kontrolle über den markt nicht
verlieren wollte mäßig ist eine präsenz
als produzent derzeit trägt seinen
bergbau zum beispiel 60 prozent zur
weltweiten produktion von seltenen erden
bei die chinesischen raffinerien für
seltene erden kaufen jedoch einen großen
teil dieses rohstoffs aus dem ausland
auf und verhindern so dass diese länder
zu lieferanten für den westen berg
diese art von strategie ist der grund
warum china weiterhin den globalen markt
zu seltenen erden dominiert auch wenn
dabei ein handelskrieg mit den
vereinigten staaten in hessen wurde und
für den fall dass es wieder zu
konflikten kommt hat peking bereits
einen plan b umgesetzt denn sicher ist
sicher china steigert die produktion von
seltenen erden inmitten eines wachsenden
technologie kriegs mit den usa auf diese
weise will peking die heimische
produktion von seltenen erden um 30
prozent steigern
das passt auch zu den 90 minuten
bestrebungen des riesen der zum beispiel
dafür sorgen will dass bis 2035 alle im
land verkauften fahrzeuge elektrisch
oder zumindest hybrid fahren wir haben
es also mit einem technologie krieg zu
tun die sich die usa in einem solchen
szenario stellen müssen und nicht nur
das wir können euch ganz ähnliche
diagramme aus japan oder der eu
präsentieren all dies spielt sich
ausgerechnet ist sondern eher ab in der
die 17 chemische elemente hätten erde
für die hightech industrie in
entwickelten ländern immer wichtiger
werden die große frage die wir uns
stellen müssen lautet also hat die welt
überhaupt eine alternative zu diesem
horrorszenario für lange zeit den
wünschen der kommunistischen partei
chinas ausgeliefert zu sein
ok schauen wir uns das mal an das ist
also bitte gut auf
[Musik]
der kampf um seltene erden
ich glaube nicht dass ich euch daran
erinnern muss was in letzter zeit die
beziehungen zwischen peking und
washington ein wenig nun ja auf der
kippe stehen wir müssen uns nur an den
handelskriege sanktionen erinnern welche
die us regierung im vergangenen
september 2020 gegen unternehmen wie
huawei oder sms center managerin
international corporation chinas großen
hersteller ergriffen habt doch
offensichtlich war präsident vielen pink
nord news und wollen dem treiben nicht
tatenlos zusehen
dezember 2020 verabschiedet in china ein
neues exportkontrolle gesetzt für
strategische materialien wonach dick in
den export dieser mineralien willkürlich
bezeichnet kann er jetzt schon die gute
alte ausrede der nationalen sicherheit
vielleicht die älteste politische
ausrede der welt aber wartet einen
moment denn das ist noch nicht fest
[Musik]
die jüngste idee chinas hat auf der
halben welt die alarmglocken schrillen
lassen
china verschärft vorschriften für
seltene erden und überwacht die gesamte
lieferkette mit diesen neuen gesetz
beabsichtigt das kommunistische regime
nichts weniger als alles was mit
seltenen erden zu tun hat unter seine
kontrolle zu bringen
vom abbau bis zum extra einschließlich
der gesamten industriellen verarbeitung
und die mineralien in raffinierte
mitteilung zu wandeln und diese dann zu
produkten weiter zu verarbeiten sodass
sie für die herstellung anderer güter
vorbereitet sind seines festplatten oder
tomahawk-raketen geschaut was ist alles
der kunde theoretisch erscheint es als
unwahrscheinlich dass china erwägen
würde den haaren komplett zuzudrehen
dies würde ja auch chinesischen
batteriehersteller schaden die ihre
produkte an us unternehmen liefern aber
für den fall dass erstmal wirklich hart
auf hart kommt stellen sich im westen
natürlich vier diplomaten und
geheimdienstler die frage was um alles
in der welt getan werden könnte wenn die
chinesen dennoch auf den roten knopf
drücken und genau an diesem punkt
blicken alle nach japan
japan versucht bereits seit einem
jahrzehnt sich aus der abhängigkeit der
chinesischen kommunisten zu lösen welche
strategie schlug also japan ein nach den
diplomatischen zwischenfall 2010 von dem
ich am anfang erzählt haben nur ein im
grunde konzentrierte es sich auf drei
themen das erste war effizienz
[Applaus]
die japanischen hersteller reduziert die
menge an seltenen erden benötigt wird um
ein bestimmtes produkt herzustellen
mit anderen worten kleinere motoren
benötigen weniger neodym und obwohl
japan heute mehr elektro und
hybridfahrzeuge herstellers noch vor
allem jahrzehnt ist die nachfrage nach
diesen metall einschließlich der
regierung und im vergleich zu 2008 um
etwa 30 prozent gesunken
die zweite maßnahme war die suche nach
alternativen lieferländer geht man zum
beispiel hat bedeutende reserven an
seltenen erden aber es fehlten die
nötigen investitionen um sie auszuwerten
und da kam die großen japanischen
technologiekonzern ins spiel die mit
viel geld ausgestattet waren ebenso wie
die regierung die hierzu sogar
ausländische unternehmen finanziell
unterstützte zum beispiel eines eine
australische bergbauunternehmen mit
einer seltenen erden raffinerie in
malaysia auf diese weise ist ist japan
gelohnt seine fast vollständige
abhängigkeit vom chinesischen importen
auf 58 prozent zu reduzieren
schließlich nahm sie jedoch noch ein
ebenso einfaches wie effektives werkzeug
in die hand
man fragte sich in tokio wenn die es
schon mitreißt und benzin machen warum
nicht auch mit seltenen erden und ihr
wisst ja die japaner sind kaum gesagt
schon getan
japan liegt strategische reserve leider
für seltenerdmetalle an als teil seiner
bemühungen seine abhängigkeit von china
zu reduzieren
das ist also anleitungen wie japan
washington und dem rest der welt mit
gibt damit sie lernen wie man mit ihr
umgehen sollte um zu verhindern dass
peking die westliche tech industrie
bestrafen kann
vorerst haben die usa den betrieb der
großen mountain pass mine wieder
aufgenommen die 2002 wegen immer
strengerer umweltauflagen in kalifornien
und weil sie nicht mehr mit den
chinesischen betrieben kooperieren
konnte geschlossen worden
darüber hinaus haben sich sowohl
demokraten als auch republikaner darauf
geeinigt dass es sich für eine straße
nahe seltenerden raffinerie einsetzen
wollen damit die gesamte verarbeitung
dieser metalle auf gutes boden erfolgt
in diesem zusammenhang wurde in colorado
bereits eine entsprechende anlage
eröffnen aber der aufbau eines solchen
projektes hochzeiten und diese anlage
wird erst 2023 erste früchte tragen
wichtig ist aber auf jeden fall dass
sich nun jeder in den usa bewusst ist
dass wir uns nicht weiter von china
abhängig machen dürfen und ja die amis
haben dass die japanische hand
aufmerksam gelesen pentagon vergibt 30
millionen dollar für selten an das
australische unternehmen leider ist
sicherlich könnte jetzt auch verstehen
warum grönland in den letzten jahren so
viele schlagzeilen gemacht hat und
demonstrant es gar für die usa kaufen
wollte ja es wird geschätzt dass es dort
riesige land nicht vorkommen gibt aber
wie auch immer
an diesem punkt ist die frage an euch
gerichtet die sollen die westlichen
länder eurer meinung nach vorgehen und
mehrere versorgung mit seltenen erden so
sicher sollten sie mit china
zusammenarbeiten oder lieber das kapital
aufbringen um dessen dominanz
herauszufordern
aber moment mal während die chinesen
seltene erden haben haben die westlichen
verbündeten etwas noch wichtigeres die
kontrolle über die halbleiterindustrie
aber darüber sprechen wir dann anderen
videothek video bleibt also handball
abonniert unseren kanal leid dieses
video und teilt es bitte auch mit euren
freunden was gut und bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]